payer pour avoir un espace réservé dans
les stationnements incitatifs
lorsqu'elle avait été évoqué au mois de
décembre
l'idée en séduisait certains je suis
prêt à payer pour stationner ici prend
le transport en commun et les molaires
et bien voilà que dès juillet l'agencé
métropolitaine de transport ira de
l'avant radio canada a mis la main sur
un document obtenu en vertu de la loi
d'accès à l'information
confirmant qu'elles seront les gares et
les stations de métro toucher une partie
des automobilistes pourra désormais
payer davance plus besoin d'arriver très
tôt le matin un père ou une mère de
famille qui est reconduit son fils
oeuvre sa fille le matin au cp ou à
l'école qui arrive aux stationnements
incitatifs après 8 heures et reste plus
de place il y a des gens un
stationnement où il est possible d'avoir
une place payante près du métro
montmorency à laval pour 119 dollars par
mois à cela s'ajouteront le
stationnement du métro namur à montréal
110 dollars par mois le métro cartier à
laval 100 dollars par mois la gare de
roxboro pierrefonds 80 dollars les gars
de deux montagnes et de s'intéresse pour
50 $ et la gare de personnes pour 40
dollars par mois plus vous êtes éloigné
du centre-ville de montréal - c'est cher
plus vous êtes rapprocher du
centre-ville de moyens plus les tarifs
sont élevés à chaque endroit ce n'est
qu'une partie des espaces qui sera
payant la majorité restera gratuite le
projet pilote ne touche pas la rive sud
puisque des problèmes pourraient
toujours survenir avec le pont champlain
par ailleurs la mt fait valoir que la
demande pour des espaces payants est
suffisante et que ce genre de tarifs
existe déjà dans des villes comme new
york boston ou encore toronto ici
françois qu'hormis radio canada ont rien